how are you Mike is doesn't forward I
did not I just made it up
do you think I like that I like that a
lot
by the way you have is that Alan Alda
yeah he's coming in and uh he's other no
he's a four-time grad you know I I do
know that he's a New Jersey guy too and
he doesn't have some time yeah yeah I'm
look I'm you nervous about I would be
nervous interviewing Alan all this well
uh we're we're all buttoned up and
produced like we're going to talk about
paper Lion with them the fact that his
mash episode that he directed the finale
is still the only non Superbowl show of
the top twenty most viewed shows in US
television history I mean there's lots
to talk about them you know iconic yes
he is iconic and maybe he's got a
problem with super teams in the NBA I
don't know maybe just does let's put it
this way Mike do you think you'd be on a
plane to Cleveland right now if Durant
stayed with Oklahoma City what do you
think oh that's odd
tell obviously you know his addition
makes them just so difficult to be I'm
with with Michael Wilbon on with the
pole
it's an emphatic yes to watch a team and
I know it's you know adding in made them
a super team to watch a team play play
the game at this level especially way
they play the unselfishness of both ends
I find as a basketball fan I feel
honored to watch it it's it's that it's
not great to watch so you know I get the
competition stuff but let's remember in
the plants each team they played in the
playoffs is missing a key player : it
doesn't go down in Game one
that's a six-game series at the very
least let's not forget George Hill who
who is the starting point guard and the
leader of that team at Utah he's not
hurt they might win a game or two so
there were other circumstances involved
that's not taking anything away from
Golden State they deserve everything
they get but I don't think wasn't for
injuries I don't think it would have
been as easy for them to get to the
files as it was this year so when you
were around this team as much as you
have all year long calling the big games
the Warriors and calling
big playoff games Mike uh what led to
the unselfishness in a in an environment
where there's so many name players
boldface name players underneath 110 how
did that all gel to what we saw from the
Warriors well I think there are two two
main reasons number one you won't have
an unselfish team unless your best
player is that way that's why the Spurs
for twenty years were the most unselfish
team in basketball because of Tim Duncan
and it's the same thing with Steph Curry
when you're in your best player is one
who cares about wings more than his
numbers it just seeps down through the
entire roster and you add a Kevin Durant
who's like that I'm just fixing like
right with everybody else because he had
that same mindset but it also starts
with your coach if you're not buying
into what the coach is saying and
because Steve Kerr has such a way he's
one of the best people persons I've ever
seen is his ability to connect with this
team
and because of his credibility of where
he came from not only as a player with
championships but who he played for like
a Popovich like a Phil Jackson he had
that credibility and they bought into
him so I think those two factors are the
key we started that and I'm not just
saying this because he's my partner but
but Mark Jackson started there his
culture of unselfishness defensively and
and Steve Kerr was so gracious and
giving more credit
there is unselfish on the defensive end
as they are on the offensive end and I
think that's what really makes them
special mike breen joining me here on
the Rich Eisen show and that's an
interesting point that you make right
there I remember uh covering the 2001
World Series on SportsCenter on ESPN and
my analyst was Buck Showalter and the
Yankee team and the Diamondback teams
that were playing for the World Series
were built by him I mean he was the
manager for the Yankees prior to Torey
and then he was the first Diamondbacks
manager and then Brenly came in and took
him to the championship and I could just
tell he there was a little bit of
melancholy it was professional and had a
sense of humor about himself what has it
been like for Mark Jackson to be calling
these games courtside watching the
Warriors win
two out of the last three years like I
think there's a sense of pride that's
part of it and he doesn't hold any
bitterness whatsoever I'm amazed how
good he is I'm not that I wouldn't be
that strong but he's proud of the
players that he watched conventionally
and helped grow up
he's just handled so well I think the
first year and they've been a little
difficult but I think it's more pride
now you'd have to ask him but he just he
loves the way they play there's certain
players that again that he coached that
he has such great relationships with and
it's I think for him that's been fun to
watch in some ways and in terms of what
you mentioned about Curry's
unselfishness that's now two
championships yes but none of them with
him as the MVP and you know he's going
to have to take a hometown discount one
would think to help keep this team all
together klay Thompson is the guy who
some are identifying is perhaps he will
want to fly the coop and and and be if
you want the number one guy on a team
somewhere and then even Durant at some
point might have to say I want to show
that I could do it on my own that it was
Pat Riley who always used the phrase
disease of me how do you think this team
continues to avoid the disease of me
Mike I think I think they had become
addicted to winning like it's it's a
drug for them they were so distraught
after last year curry normally doesn't
say things like I was crushed said he
couldn't watch Game seven last year for
the longest time so it wanted a goal
thing that's getting overly dramatic but
they were so damaged by that last year
that it drove them to to what they did
this year will and they even sacrificed
more than they had previously so I think
that's you know that's been the key for
them if you know linkage you can never
predict whatever it's injuries whether
it's complacency whether it's jealousy
so many things can change a dynamic of
the team when you achieve success but at
least for these last two championships
I've watched it has not changed them one
bit so then how does this compare to
championship teams that you've called
before as I send the 11 times before
your doesn't mic what what the stars are
all still so young they're still on
their prime nobody's even 30 yet recline
out loud
that's a scary part and the other thing
too is look at the could Kevin Durant
you know as great as score as he was
he's become not a good he's become a
really good defender he's become more of
a playmaker so he's still developing as
a complete player
same thing with Carly Cody was a great
scorer and a good distributor but he
took on a little bit of a different role
this year as a playmaker then you have
these other two green and Thompson who
are so good defensively both
individually and team wise so they still
won't really seem to grow for crying out
loud in a second as long as you stay
healthy as long as you don't get
complacent and as long as you don't
start saying walk he's got more touches
in I do which you don't see any signs of
it and it could get better just with
familiarity of playing together more
especially now with Durant coming back
in the second season and not having that
burden of the crusher other than wanted
title so I guess my last question for
you is you say that the Warriors winning
is not a bad thing for the NBA yes it is
a good thing that the Warriors have won
for the NBA what if it does lead to more
Super teams what if it does lead to just
basically you start the season next year
and there's really only a belief in one
or two teams and have a shot at knocking
off the Warriors Mike that's not an
issue you don't think like well I don't
think it the way that the CBA is set up
I think it's very hard for it to happen
that way
it was the perfect storm with Golden
State in terms of where their star
players were at their contracts and the
exact timing that the salary cap jumped
to just extraordinary levels I think
it'd be difficult for that to happen
again so many different things had to
fall in place including Oklahoma City
losing that series again I firmly
believe that OKC got to the finals last
year and beat Golden State I don't know
if Durant leaves now I mean nobody can
tell that but I think so many things
have to fall perfectly into place for
this to happen and
still could happen but to me it's also
Richards it's a challenge to the other
general managers challenge you're the
president okay we got to figure this
thing out
this team is up here we got to find a
way or you can compete with that and I
think it brings out the best in the
basketball people have you ever called
golf Mike never called gone
I call it all the time in my living room
when I'm watching games I practice my
little secret whisper well it sounds
right it sounds like you got that going
on right now Mike are you like on a 12th
at 12th of green atop someone I'm in the
Delta Club at the airport there should
be very serious business people here
okay consumers are staring at me with
menacing glares because they've watched
a dozen NBA Finals Mike they know you
that's what it is and then they pick up
my voice right now and Rihanna just
walked by right is that weird how much
grief is there how much grief did Van
Gundy get he said he got a ton of grief
from for you in the crew it just rolls
off his back he is not bothered the
least by that kind of grief fly safe
Mike all right rich always a pleasure
book
you got it same here that's Mike Breen
so Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country and audience if you like some of
that get some more of that on the Rich
Eisen show lap follow all the
information you see right here on the
Rich Eisen show